yes oh my God look at that
Seether
everybody
so what's going on
I know not much man absolutely nothing
when you think about it which means it's
time for
so many stories
[Music]
thank you
some news
[Music]
you ever wonder how local news becomes
National it happened in Montgomery
Alabama a city-owned Riverboat tried to
dock in its designated spot along the
Waterfront but a pontoon boat was moored
there cops say the captain of the
Riverboat asked the pontoons owners to
move but was ignored and when a deckhand
of the Riverboat would ashore to move
the smaller boat hmm the owners weren't
happy about it at all and then this
happened mind you what you are about to
see is disturbing so if you have
children in the room punch them hard in
the face as a diversion foreign
[Applause]
number two years
the reinforcements
well that's disgusting appalling and
when I've discussed it and appalled I
need to see more
oh
[Music]
oh my God
oh that hurts and then more people
jumped in to defend the guy and it
turned into quite the melee or what the
Irish call Friday night
but it's what the rest of us might call
just plain good TV which explains how
this quickly went from a local story to
a national one the fact is fights are
interesting we'll watch a fight some Far
Away Parliament rather than go to a
council meeting in our own neighborhood
especially when it's set to heavy metal
[Music]
thank you
yes see what I mean but that can't be
the only reason why a story about a
fight on a Riverfront married so much
attention hell cable news actually took
the local press conference the police
press conference live and that's
including us is it because we think Aunt
Helen and Boise might know one of the
Brawlers in Montgomery or are we just
filling up space to help out a restless
and bored and anxious country there is
no point to cover this story but
everyone did so who's the bad guy in
this brawl I guess I should have an
opinion if I don't then I'm not doing my
job I might as well be Bill Himmler
[Music]
it just makes him mad when I get home
guys were parked where they weren't
supposed to be parked and they should
have just moved their boat but they
didn't so you end up with this fight and
because it was whites versus blacks you
got something even more newsworthy race
I'm sure if it were white on white or
black on black it would matter less but
it wasn't and that brings me to another
vital part of the story the black guy
who got attacked says it had nothing to
do with race despite what his co-workers
say and cops did consult with the FBI to
determine if it could have been a hate
crime they concluded it wasn't after
again the guy who got attacked told the
cops he didn't believe it was racially
motivated anyway
and that's despite another person
claiming to have heard the n-word so the
guy who got jumped isn't calling this a
race fight then why should anybody else
the truth is with anything like this
there could be bad dudes and good dudes
on both sides and that's got nothing to
do with race but the moment there are
groups of a specific type the media has
taught us to see that variable first
rather than the actual individuals
Within
anyway let's be honest the video of the
fight is better than 98 of what you see
on Netflix
seriously why have you not even noticed
the writer's strike
because that void the place where we
seek entertainment is now found in the
same place as our news news and
entertainment are indistinguishable it's
like when my wife asked me if I've had
dinner and I say I already ate but it
was Three Margaritas
huh drinks are dinner and entertainment
is news and the good news is the people
who get in fights on planes and trains
and now loading docks they never Strike
they're always here when you need them
maybe we should pause and give them a
moment of appreciative silence
[Music]
oh
the amazing thing about life these days
we've democratized entertainment one day
you could be minding your own business
looking at videos on your phone and the
next day you're what's being watched in
a video on that phone could happen to
any of us the most local of stories can
go National and we treat it like news
when it's really just chewing gum for a
restless and anxious Soul it's something
to do until you've chewed the flavor out
of that event no lasting impact unless
it's you in that video and that's
something to remember at any moment you
can become news and the odds are you
will No One Is Safe especially in the
summer when the people behind the scenes
stop making up the news and leave it to
the rest of us and it's safe to say I
think we're doing a better job
[Applause]
she puts the fox and Fox News oh so this
story more than Michaela
he thought Love is All You Need until he
lost half his stuff actor writer and
comedian Jamie Liza
she's a woman of the people and those
people are weirdos Fox News contributor
tattoo
and finally black cats avoid him for bad
luck my massive sides
foreign
involves a number of variables you've
got uh fights brawls you've got race uh
who's the expert here on this cat no
you haven't brawled in years all right
tires we had a conversation about this
uh last night and you had a very
interesting take on it well the first
thing we don't talk enough about how
much the pandemic has hurt us and we've
saw it because we've lost the ability to
fight
[Laughter]
everybody in here this that was the
worst fight I've ever seen in my life
across the board and I used to blame bad
fighting on white people but my people
showed up and together everyone was out
of breath you don't throw a punch and
try not to get hit at the same time it
just doesn't work
that and the fight was so bad that women
were getting punched and
okay with that yeah like there wasn't
one person that went on TV was like
these men were hitting women yeah
because the women had a Fighting Chance
there's one
where hits her and she's like did you
did you just hit me
so there's the quality yeah I'm happy to
see it but I mean what has happened to
us is fighting and you can't listen when
you're fighting someone you are going to
say stuff yeah okay so there probably
was a couple in bombs that went out
there
probably from us talking to us
coordinating our attack
and then
one very scared white guy was like
a chair there's a setup but it's the
fighting was awful and I'm glad that the
man came up and said it had nothing to
do with race and had everything to do
with bad beer no cardio yeah and two
overall just laziness that's a astute
analysis now I want to go to the news
side Martha uh we we actually did the
press conference yeah this and it's kind
of hit is it because it's news or
because we just like gratuitously
bizarre stuff I mean it's like it's like
this is there's hundreds thousands of
people and suffering every day but this
was the story because it's just fun to
watch I'm gonna go with Choice B yes um
I think that that's probably in our news
decision making process when I came into
my meeting that morning everyone said
did you see the video yeah have you seen
the fight um but I asked myself why this
stuff seems to happen more often now and
and you point to covet and I'm thinking
that it has something to do with the
Nexus of of bad beer cocktails and not
enough clothing yes it's like when
people are too casual they tend to get
into fights like look at what happens
when people wear sweatpants at the
airport these women are pulling each
other's hair out and I'm thinking to
myself did this happen during Victorian
times did people who were like corseted
and wearing large skirts women rip each
other's hair out and throw each other on
the floor at the airport I don't think
so no because they didn't have airports
Martha that's true she's right back then
you had to formally slap somebody with a
glove would be an arrangement in a party
the only downside is somebody had to go
though is insult to them but these
people are the best of us
I'm Lim and say that the Pontoon folks
are probably not the best of them yeah
and they also when they got handcuffed
they look totally non-plus they're like
yeah this happens yeah
I want to reach that stage in my life
where I get arrested and it's just like
another day yeah they're just like yeah
whatever they're just sitting on the
dock Jamie did that remind you of how
your divorce went yeah yeah what you
didn't see that one coming
that road itself I'm a little disgusted
by it personally yeah this really hit
home I now only have half a pontoon boat
[Music]
[Laughter]
it really was though I loved the I loved
it the whole watching it I just love it
was like watching MMA where no one
trained
you know and then you're right about the
Netflix thing like about people watch
this more than that like I have a TV
show on Netflix it took a year to write
I should have just thought Tyrus
that would have been too short maybe
build your way up
for the family benefits how about the
cover coverage on these fights though
that had more camera angles than my
comedy special like there were so many
people and my favorite part was the um
was the folding chair wasn't the folding
chair the the folding chair is the only
piece of furniture that's just as
comfortable to be hit with as decided
it is true though why would you hit
somebody with a chair well I mean it's
like it's that's a lot of work gotta
lift it up yeah hit him with your fist
did you see them fighting Grace they're
big Jerry Springer fans yes exactly
that's where it started so cat uh what
did you make have you ever been in the
middle of a brawl
no I was so close though because I do
have a show in Montgomery Alabama this
upcoming Sunday August 13th tickets are
available at the realcatpiff.com why
don't you have oh my God you should have
the the both sides uh to open the show
it was trending on Twitter when I was in
the hotel for another one of my live
shows and I was like oh what happened
you know I assumed drunken fight but I
have a question for Martha if that's
okay because we share a wall our offices
are next to each other so she knows that
I come to work every day in track pants
and a hoodie and I I don't have a corset
on underneath either do you think I'm a
violent person I think could possibly go
down that road careful I've never been
in a fight ever not to brag yeah
you have stabbed people no why does
everybody always think that
it was I mean nobody's defending these
pontoon jerks right yeah like bail fund
for these losers no everybody hates
these guys yeah there's no go for at
least give them free fight lessons yeah
that's the least you can do yeah there's
actually a gofund yourself yeah
all right before we go a quick reminder
I've got some amazing guest comedians
for the next stop on my book tour Tom
shaloo Jamaica
Jim Norton Joe Mackey and Nick depaolo
September 16th Reading PA go to G
gutfeld.com for Ticket info hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else